哈囉我是小三雷
今天分享集團絕對不會溫鬥的游鬥機
可又變雙
我曾經花了將近三千塊錢買了一款貴富麵雙款
結果用完之後我的臉上一夜之間長了十幾個鬥
游鬥機在驗雙和防曬的選擇上要有其想興
這兩個後付品位是最容易彩雷溫鬥的
不要去重上大牌或者是貴富險
我們選擇面雙的第一標準應該是不制鬥
其次在這球攻下
今天跟講的這四款面雙把我們可以放心
都是我用的很久
效果很好確定他們絕對不會溫鬥的
那今天都分享給你們
先說這一款
這個是粉絲推薦給我的
它真是太好用了
它不是什麼細水長流
要堅持才能看到效果的
它是你用一次就會被它經驗一次
等來感覺皮膚有一點粗糙了
但我只要用它第二天起來
我就會發現我的皮膚變細膩、光滑而且還有光澤了
它擁有百分之十的單純酸
所以它並不是很溫和
我第一次用它的時候上臉有幾秒鐘溫約的自痛
但我後面用它就沒有什麼感覺
適合比較耐受的皮膚
如果你的皮膚不平滑不信你
又是一個耐受品
你一定要試試它
它的效果和我之前分享的六酸精華很像
但它比六酸精華要便宜很多
而且它可以用來擦身體
它擦身體的效果也很好
皮膚會變得很滑
至低就是這種像一個酸奶的質地
它的質地不算是很清爽
但是絕對不年齡
反正我不管我擦它
我就去睡覺第二天就是一個細膩光澤積
然後就是這個小可愛
我已經用它用了很多了
它可以做一層的入門面雙
裡面是有添加了添鮮安的
添鮮安可以讓一層的效果更好
也可以增強皮膚的一個耐受力
膚感很好
一點都不有膩
而且很溫和
我用它基本上沒有什麼耐受起
最後一會有屁來說
保持痛鋼剛好
比一些保持面雙還要做得更好
我一般就是耐受精華
在加上它皮膚不流也不乾
而且它很便宜
即使快點就能買到
效果也不錯
但是我之前也是分享過的
它的香味好好聞
我每期用它
我都覺得自己好上雨心
它也是最重
凝霜的致敵
很輕薄做早晚間的
保持面雙都可以
很適合年輕積不來用
對遊皮完全沒有負擔
裡面有一些看兩話
成分很適合學生打
然後就是一個黑老面雙
這款我沒有上兩過
我是用來做景霜的
我之前用的景霜都是千元
以上的大排景霜
但其實說實話效果也還好
因為黑老這個事情
它不是力乾淨
它是需要時間來檢驗成果的
那我現在都是用一些
黑老的面雙來做的景霜
我覺得效果也還不錯
我的景文沒有變得更嚴重
它的膚感是這種土豆泥的致敵
它完之後皮膚是假光的
很好吸收
對於做景霜來說
我覺得性價比很高
我們的脖子
我覺得是需要好好保養的
但是並不需要專業的景霜
我的景文以前是很嚴重的那種
但我現在都感覺我的景文
真的是有環節一些
不是說到沒有
但是真的是有景質一點
而且它沒有在面眼中下去了
我覺得這就是有效果的
而且我用它按我的脖子沒有掌豆豆
那這次款就是我這一切的分享
現在其實我分享游動機可用的
不滿豆的舒服面雙核擊
想看的飽飽可以給我點贊收藏加關注哦
那我們下次見
拜拜